il ya quelques semaines nous recevions
sur ce plateau le président d' équilibre
une association humanitaire qui
dénonçait l'état de délabrement des
hôpitaux irakiens
six ans après la mise en place de
l'embargo une de nos équipes s'est rendu
sur place
la situation vous allez le voir est
toujours très difficile en irak bono le
bref auger motte
c'est la dernière couverture chauffante
à peu près en état de marche
elle est à l'image des hôpitaux irakiens
après six ans d'embargo
la visite est édifiante pas besoin
d'être spécialiste en médecine pour
comprendre l'ampleur du problème
les chirurgiens nous explique tout de
même qu'ils n'ont droit qu'à cinq
opérations par semaine seuls les cas les
plus urgents sont traités aux
anesthésiants en coûte pour éclairer la
salle fil pour recoudre les malades
l'hôpital universitaire de bagdad est
pourtant l'un des plus modernes du pays
son équipement de radiologie ces
scanners n'ont rien à envier aux nôtres
si ce n'est le petit matériel sans
lequel rien ne fonctionne normalement on
devrait mettre une seule radio sur cette
photo mais comme mon prêt paquets de
produits de développement
j'en ai plusieurs alors bien sûr on
vraiment agréable regardez le nombre de
fautes de goût total 11 photos il faut
tout économiser et le constat est le
même dans tous les services
le professeur dilemme célèbre chirurgien
orthopédiste français n'en est pas à son
premier voyage en irak
mais à chaque fois pour lui c'est le
même choc impossibilité de réaliser des
interventions majeures dans ces
conditions
est aussi faillite de la médecine yakin
est le troisième élément qui intervient
c'est la malnutrition qui touche
sélectivement les enfants le nombre de
décès par
malnutrition alors qu'il était
pratiquement nul avant 1989 est de
l'ordre de 1000 par an
actuellement depuis deux mois l'irak
peut à nouveau acheter de la nourriture
et des produits médicaux mais il faudra
plusieurs années au pays pour retrouver
sa capacité de soins d'avant l'embargo